房產關鍵字
帶你掌握新趨勢
大家好
歡迎收看今天的節目
我是Amy
不知道大家有沒有發現
央行從2024年
9月19日開始的
第七波信用管制
已經要滿2年
而且央行也鬆口說
不會再有更嚴格的
房貸管制政策
那究竟未來房市
會怎麼轉變
為什麼過了這2年的
房市的這麼的冷靜期
價格還是這麼硬
我們現在到底
能不能夠買
今天就為大家邀請到了
房產專家
永慶房屋業管部的協理
陳賜傑
為我們帶來了詳細的
數據分析
要來告訴我們房市的
真實內幕
協理你好
主持人好
各位觀眾朋友
大家好
協理
其實我們從剛剛講到的
這個第七波的信用管制
還有房貸的緊縮的政策
其實都是政府為了要來
打擊這些炒作
還有抑制過熱的房市
但是實際上
過了這2年
這個房市到底有沒有
什麼樣的變化了
Amy很厲害
我想其實剛才已經
很精準的提到
這一次央行的政策目的
我想其實央行祭出
這些管制的措施
最主要的是要抑制
給多屋族
從這個貸款成數的
部分來限制
但是
它同時也要照顧
有些是自用的換屋需求
所以它也適度的開放了
這是針對第二戶以上的
房貸成數的一個上限
能夠放鬆
對這個換屋族的貸款限制
那最近又推出了最新的
這個青安3.0的優惠貸款
它主要是要優先支持
就是目前沒有房的
首購族
然後讓這個房屋買賣
能夠回歸到
自住的一個需求
我們可以從最近幾年的
這個建物買賣移轉棟數
來發現市場確實
跟之前比起來
是明顯的降溫了
那六都的都會區
在2025的上半年的
買賣移轉棟數
年減幅達到26%
那2026上半年
也還有在相對微降了
大概3%
所以減這個減幅
已經有大幅的收斂
所以從這一年半看來
整體的房屋市場
應該整體趨於
比較穩定的一個現象
但是協理
我還是想要再請教
因為你剛剛的圖表裡面
我們雖然說看到這個
買賣移轉棟數
是有往下滑
然後你也說到
會趨於穩定
但是我們身邊很多的
朋友都開始在看房子
實際上到這個房市
這樣進去看
沒有感覺穩定
到底這個買賣移轉棟數
它這個組成分是什麼
那其實在整個不動產的
買賣移轉棟數裡面
它裡面包含了幾個成分
第一個是成屋的交易件數
那另外也包含了
預售屋完工後的交屋
所以預售屋也在裡面
那另外還有就是
一般民眾自己
會有些自售
自己買自己賣的
這樣的一個件數
整個都包含在這個裡面
所以你很難直接從
數字的反應就看出
實際現在成屋市場的買氣
那所以也讓
成屋市場的市況
跟現階段的
建物買賣移轉棟數的數字
看起來會有些脫鉤
那我們這邊
用永慶內部的
這個指標數據來看
那其實在今年2026的
第2季的整個房市
已經有出現明顯回溫的
一個現象
我們來看這張表
我們排除掉
今年農曆年
我們的這個
因為有年假的因素
我們以1月份完整的
整個月來當作基準
我們把1月跟5月
還有6月的
房屋的看屋諮詢量
來做一個比較
其實已經有增加
超過1成以上了
分別是12.1%
跟10.4%
那而且
不只在看屋人變多
我們再看5月跟6月的
實際的成交量
也跟1月比較
分別增加了15.4%
跟7%
這數字都說明了
從整個房屋不只
諮詢量的提升
其實從後端的成交
也明顯有一些增長
也顯示
這幾個月的房屋的買氣
其實已經有明顯的提升
非常感謝協理帶來
市場上這麼即時的
一手的資訊
看來今年的買氣
確實是有在回升
Amy說的沒錯
那我們這邊也準備了
永慶房產集團內部的
成交數據
來跟觀眾朋友做分享喔
我們看
從今年的第2季開始
那整個交易的量
成長是相對有感
我們把4月的成交年增
是17%
那5月的年增是23%
那6月也維持年增
有16%的表現
所以整體
跟去年比較起來
其實相對是
明顯的成長
那如果接下來的整體的
經濟能夠維持
穩健的成長
而且我們出口一樣維持
現在的這個暢旺
另外是台股繼續維持
在這個高檔
我們推估在2026年的
第3季的房市的交易量
應該還是有小增的機會
所以整體這樣來看的話
我們現在的成屋市場
是有逐漸在回溫了
然後成交量也是彈升了
那預售屋的市場
現在表現又是如何
我們就從預售屋的
實價登錄的數據來看
我想整體預售屋
在這2年買氣
確實有變得比較冷清
那我們也分析統計了
今年1到6月的
預售屋的實價登錄
我們看到每個月平均
大概只有3000件左右的成交
這樣子的話
這2年預售屋
它的交易量真的
是會很不樂觀了
對嗎
我想回歸到這次
政策的本質
它就是要降低房地產的
投機炒作
所以第一個就是投機客
已經大幅度的退出
這個預售的市場
第二個
也因為政策的關係
有些自住的買方心態
也會轉為比較觀望
那所以預售屋市場的
這個買氣確實就
因此受到了影響
那也因為整個去化速度變慢
所以整個預售屋
在市場的待售庫存
是持續的增加
那我們準備一張表
跟觀眾朋友也來分享
我們從數據來看
全台在2023年以前
推出的預售屋的
建案銷售率
都有突破8成
我想各都大概都落在
這個地方
那2024年的
第七波信用管制之後
我們看得到買氣
大幅的減少
那預售建案的銷售率
也掉到5成
2025年以後的預售
這個建案的銷售率
更只剩下2成多
那我們來細看
七大都會區的銷售狀況
除了雙北市
因為這個自住的需求
相對比較強勁
那加上供給的量
也比較少
所以還勉強維持
有在4成的銷售率
那其他我們看從
桃園以南
這2年的銷售率
平均都不到2成
這個數字
真的非常的驚人
代表說很多的預售屋
建案開出來
可能賣不到2成
這個買氣就凍結了
而且
大家不敢買預售的原因
應該就是價格開了
實在是太高了
已經高不可攀了
而且也聽說就是
這個雙北市場的
這個成屋和預售屋
它的這個價差
已經足足可以快要
買一台國產汽車了
到底為什麼這個價差
會這麼大
我們這邊也準備了
台北市今年的預售屋平均單價
來跟觀眾朋友分享
我們看到2026年
1到4月的預售屋
平均單價是落在130萬元
那我們看另外一條線
是針對成屋
成屋的大樓
大概只有82萬元
這一來一回單價就差了
48萬元
我想價差幅度
逼近到了6成
如果把它轉換成
購屋的總價
我們用30坪的房屋
來做計算
30坪乘以48萬元
價差就將近1500萬元
我想這樣的價差
對購屋族來講
確實是
不小的一個負擔
這個48萬元是
不知道怎麼來的
真的很驚人
那我們再來看一看新北市
我們看一下
這個新北市的價差
它的差距
有沒有比較縮小一點
我們來看
新北市的這一張表
一樣我們在今年1到4月
新北市的預售屋
平均單價
落到72萬元
那成屋的大樓是46萬元
一樣來回價差的
有26萬元
這個幅度
跟台北市比起來
差一點點
但是其實也已經
逼近了6成的價差
那我想我們觀眾
應該有看到
我們剛剛的那兩張的表格
那這個預售屋
跟中古屋的價差
真的是逐年在增加擴大
那協理可以幫我們
來分析一下
到底這兩條線
為什麼會價差
這麼的巨大
沒有問題
那我想
建商它在推預售屋
有幾個考量點
我想第一個
它在訂價的時候
就土地成本
還有營建成本
那再來就是人工成本
當然另外它最重要
它的合理的一個利潤
那現在從土地建材
跟人工成本
是越來越高
那建商要能夠主動讓利
我想這個狀況會比較少
那所以它整個
整體的價格彈性
相對就比較小
所以預售的價格
它不容易往下走
那我們反觀成屋市場
最大的優勢是什麼
因為每個案子
每個房屋出售的
業主都不同
動機也不同
那所以它的價格彈性
比較大
也能夠比較快速反應
現階段市場的一個變化
那回到消費者買房的
角度來看
成屋它能夠買到的坪數
會比預售屋買到的坪數
來得大
因為單價的差異
那所以
這以上這些條件也讓
近期的成屋市場
會比預售屋市場的
這個表現
來得穩定
沒錯
按照現在當前市場
這樣的風向
就是買方的一個需求
換成是我的話
我也會選擇
這種看得到又摸得到
然後價格又相對親民的成屋
我再來還是想要
再來問問看協理
因為畢竟每個人買房
他的需求會不一樣
所以就是
針對像接下來
要買房子的人
他們在看預售屋
然後看成屋
協理
可不可以再給我們一些
買方的建議
然後或者是
是不是可以善用
像青安3.0這樣的政策
OK
我想不管是選預售屋
或中古屋
其實這都沒有好壞
沒有對錯
那主要關鍵在於
消費者在買房之前的
從對資金的準備
還有入住的時間
還有對屋況的接受度
以及未來能不能承擔
在預售屋交屋時候的
一些不確定性
那如果是想要
買成屋或中古屋
目前我們建議消費者
是非常好的
進場看屋的時機
那也是詢價的
一個好時機
那目前整體
中古屋的房價
相對是比較穩定
那甚至有一些部分
供給可能比較大的區域
它價格
有些小幅度的修正
也比較明顯
那價格相對也比較友善
再加上現在
整體市場的供給量
是屬於大的
那對於有
自住首購需求的買方
非常適合這個時候
出來看房子
它也有足夠的時間
能夠看充足的房子
再來做最後的決定
那如果他是
想要買預售屋
那我們建議消費者
就是多看多比較
雖然買預售屋
確實前期的負擔
因為施工期長
負擔比較輕
但是交屋之後
就直接面臨到了付款
跟每個月要還貸款這件事情
那就要精算清楚
避免交屋之後
有資金上面缺口的風險
那看屋前
同時也要慎選
有口碑
以及施工品質好的建商
也避免買到了爛尾樓
沒辦法交屋
或交屋的時候
整個品質不如預期
那尤其在各區
在各建案的銷售情形
決定之前不需要太衝動
還是符合多看多比價
然後再積極的議價
爭取自己合理
以及能負擔的價格
那不過
還是要提醒消費者
那中古屋
是看得到也摸得到
它不需要等
兩三年的這個施工期
然後如果
對於坪數的
需求量比較高
或是重視生活機能的
不妨利用這個時間
優先考慮
中古屋跟成屋
會更能夠符合
自身的一個需求選擇
謝謝協理
真的是非常實用的建議
那我還是要
再請教協理
因為我們現在時序
已經來到了第3季了
那接下來下半年
我們有沒有
哪一些的關鍵因素
都要持續的來關注
會不會還有什麼
會來影響到我們房市
那目前
有3個關鍵因素
要提醒觀眾朋友
能夠掌握
第一個就是政策
第二個是房貸緊縮
第三個就是通膨
我們要注意
在房市的政策
有沒有維持
或是有新的政策出來
第二個
銀行現在有沒有錢
來做放款的部分
第三個就是通膨
是不是穩定的狀況
那這些都會影響
下半年房市的一個表現
那對一般的民眾來說
其實在央行
選擇性信用管制下
銀行現在是
自主的風險控管
那對於房貸的審核標準
還是相對的嚴格
那貸款的成數
以及利率的條件
也是相對的受限
當然能不能如期的貸款到
你所需要的成數
這個還是要
事先先做查詢
那這也是
目前在買屋的消費者
他優先要去
注意的幾個點
那不過央行
它對於換屋族的貸款成數
有小幅度的鬆綁
那另外財政部
也推出了青安3.0
可以持續的
支持首購族
那預估未來整體的房市
會轉趨穩定而且健康
非常謝謝協理
這麼多的
這個房市的分析
還有建議
那我們就來總結一下
今天的節目內容
在央行
還沒有鬆綁
這個信用管制之下
買方購物決策
仍然是趨向於保守的
因此相較於變動性高
房價又持續創新高的
預售屋
成屋
反而是看得到又摸得到
價格
又親民(將近6成)
所以買方
在資金有限的情況之下
自然就會轉向
相較於這個市場
比較友善的成屋
那永慶房屋
也預測2026年的第3季
成屋市場也即將呈現
量小增、價平的走勢
未來市場
還會如何的變動
我們就要來緊盯
持續的關注
政策有沒有改變
銀行有沒有錢借
還有通膨會如何的來變化了
Amy說的完全正確
那接下來只要消費者
掌握這三大核心
就能夠精準的對應
接下來的市場變化
非常感謝協理
今天所帶來的
這麼精彩的趨勢分析
還有數據的解讀
想要掌握
最精確最核心的
房市資訊
一定要記得
鎖定《房產關鍵字》
再次謝謝協理來到
我們今天這裡的節目
那我們就下次見
謝謝協理今天的分享